♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
JUST KILLED CRITICAL RACE THEORY
TRAINING AND FEDERAL AGENCIES,
THE STUFF THAT CLAIMS ALL WHITE
PEOPLE ARE RACIST.
ONCE AGAIN, THE BIG ORANGE MEAN
HE HAS SOMETHING NO ONE HAD THE
GUTS TO DO BEFORE, ERADICATE A
PUNITIVE IDEOLOGY THAT RUINS
BUSINESSES AND ALLIES, A DISEASE
BORN FROM THEIR HATEFUL HALLS OF
LEFT-WING ACADEMIA, CRITICAL
RACE THEORY UNDERMINES THE
POSITIVE CORE BELIEFS OF AMERICA
BY REDEFINING THE NATION AS AN
ENGINE OF OPPRESSION.
THIS LEADS TO DISCORDANT
SCHOOLS, FAMILIES, AND NOW EVEN
WORK.
THE TOP ATTRIBUTE OF A GREAT
EMPLOYEE, POSITIVE ATTITUDE.
CRTV REPLACES THAT WITH
GRIEVANCE AND ENVY AND WHAT YOU
ARE SEEING ON AMERICAN CITY
STREETS ARE ITS RESULTS,
STARTING ON CAMPUS AND LEAKING
INTO UNCONSCIOUS BIAS TRAINING
AND WORK, CULMINATING IN BY
WRITER IS USING THIS IDEOLOGY TO
JUSTIFY VIOLENCE.
THEY’VE BEEN BRAINWASHED FOR
THINK YOU ARE UNCONSCIOUSLY
RACIST AND THEY ARE THERE TO
WAKE YOU UP.
UNCONSCIOUSLY RACIST MEANS EVEN
WHEN YOU SAY YOU ARE INTO RAGE
RACIST, THE RESPONSE IS "YOU ARE
NOT CONSCIOUS OF IT."
THOSE WHO DEMAND INDOCTRINATION
OPERATE ON THEIR OWN UNCONSCIOUS
RACISM, THEY PRESUME ALL WHITE
PEOPLE ARE THE SAME WAY,
POSSESSING WHITE PRIVILEGE.
THAT IS CONSCIOUS RACISM.
LET’S HOPE THIS BRAVERY SPREADS
IN THE SURVIVAL OF OUR COUNTRY
DEPENDS ON IT.
ALL RIGHT, WE WILL GO FAST HERE,
GOOD MOVE ON TRUMP’S PART?
>> Dana: POSSIBLY ALTHOUGH I
DO THINK THERE IS GOING TO BE
SOME PUSHBACK BUT I THINK THERE
IS NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE THAT
UNDERSTAND WHAT CRT IS AND IT
COMES ALONG THIS YEAR AS WE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS PROJECT FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BASICALLY
TRYING TO REDEFINE THE BIRTH OF
AMERICA.
I WOULD SAY THIS, IF THERE’S NOT
GOING TO BE CRT WHICH I DON’T
NECESSARILY THINK THERE SHOULD
BE, SHOULD THERE BE BETTER
HISTORICAL EDUCATION IN OUR K-12
SCHOOLS AND EVEN IN COLLEGE?
BECAUSE I THINK OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, WE ARE TRYING TO EXPLAIN
TO OUR VIEWERS WHO ARE ALREADY
PROBABLY PRETTY WELL-INFORMED
ABOUT OUR NATION’S HISTORY AND
THAT AS TO BE RE-EXAMINED.
EDUCATION IN OUR COUNTRY,
HISTORIC EDUCATION IN OUR
COUNTRY ABSOLUTELY HAS TO BE
SOMETHING WE DEAL WITH AND
THAT’S NOT SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT CAN DEAL WITH, SCHOOLS
ARE RUN BY PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEY SHOULD BE AT
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING AND
LEARNING OUR HISTORY WE ARE
GOING TO BE IN A PRETTY TOUGH
SITUATION LIKE WE ARE THIS
SUMMER.
>> Greg: EMILY, I THINK CRT IS
ONE OF THE WORST THINGS THAT’S
EVER BEEN INVENTED IN MY LIFE
AND IT CREATES AN ATTITUDE THAT
REPLACES OPTIMISM AND DESIRE FOR
OPPORTUNITY WITH GRIEVANCE AND
ENVY, WHY WOULD ANYBODY WANT TO
HIRE SOMEBODY LIKE THAT?
>> Emily: TRYING TO APPLY IT
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, IT’S
TRYING TO APPLY SOMEONE’S
INDIVIDUAL PARADIGM TO SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT, I KNOW WHAT
RESOURCE UTILIZATION LOOKS LIKE,
IT WOULD BE A COLOSSAL WASTE OF
TIME AND A WASTE OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND A HUGE STUDY
CONDUCTED OF OUR MAMMOTH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THE 80 AND 90 PLUS
PERCENTAGE OF EMPLOYEES, WHAT
THEY REALLY WANT TRAINING AND AT
WHAT THEY THINK WOULD BENEFIT
THE CITIZENS ARE THINGS LIKE
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION AND
REDUCING SECURITY AND PRIVACY
REQUIREMENTS, THINGS THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
HOW OUR GOVERNMENT RUNS AND HOW
WE SEE THOSE BENEFITS, NOT THE
SORT OF FANTASYLAND STUFF.
>> Greg: EVEN LIBERALS LIKE
THIS BECAUSE THEY SAW CRT
UNDERMINING THE SOFT AND HARD
SCIENCES IN ACADEMIA AND IN FACT
EVERYTHING WITH THE IDEOLOGY OF
RACE.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING ON BEHALF OF WHITE
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW.
DANA, HOLD MY HAND.
BEFORE NOW I’M SCARED.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A TEST, IT
WAS A JOKE.
I JUST WAS SEEING IF DANA WAS
PAYING ATTENTION.
DANA, YOU STOPPED ME, GOOD JOB.
JUST BEING A JESSE WATTERS I
FEEL GUILT, I DON’T NEED
ADDITIONAL GUILT FOR MY RACE.
A LOT OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH
MONEY AND POWER, THE PEOPLE WHO
RUN THESE SEMINARS, RADICAL
SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIOR LAWYERS,
YOU PAY THEM TO DO THE SURVEY
AND IS ALSO A GOOD WAY IF YOU
WANT TO TO TO GET PEOPLE FIRED O
PROMOTED WITH THINGS THAT ARE
NOTHING TO DO WITH WORK PRODUCTS
PRODUCTS.
>> Geraldo: MY PROBLEM WITH
THE 1619 PROJECT IS ITS NARROW
FOCUS, YOU KNOW, I AM OVER 10%
NATIVE AMERICAN WHICH MEANS THAT
10% OF MY DESCENDANTS WERE HERE
THOUSANDS OF YEARS BEFORE,
LATINOS ARE THE BIGGEST MINORITY
GROUP IN THIS COUNTRY,
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE TO BE
RECOGNIZED AS WELL, WE HAVE THIS
LASER FOCUS, THIS NARROW FOCUS
ON A MINORITY THAT HAS BEEN
OPPRESSED AND JUSTLY NEEDS
RECOGNITION FOR THAT OPPRESSION
AND DISCRIMINATION.
SO DO OTHER GROUPS AS WELL IN
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS WITH